hendrik strick ist bei uns den ich
gleich zu beginn gerne fragen würde oder
franken muss die großschlachterei
turniers meldet einen ich finde im kreis
gütersloh ziemlich großen ausbruch von
von corona 7000 menschen unter
quarantäne
mehr als 400 infiziert wieder eine
schlachterei und sie haben gerade kurz
bevor die sendung angefangen hat gesagt
ja das zeigt mal wieder die launen der
natur warum
erstmal also ich glaube aus diesem
ausbruch können wir sehr viel lernen und
ich hoffe das wird auch sehr gut
aufgezeichnet und vielleicht gehen auch
hygieniker rein um das ein bisschen
besser zu verstehen diesen ausbruch weil
ist es einmal bei einer
routineuntersuchung aufgefallen ist es
nicht aufgefallen weil menschen im
krankenhaus gelandet sind vermehrt also
man kann jetzt schon mal erst mal davon
ausgehen ist ein eher milde
symptomatischen moderate symptomen nicht
etwas wo die intensivstationen jetzt
nadel überlaufen werden
zweiter punkt der interessantes ist es
in einem staat drei betrieb passiert
wieder und wir wissen von schlachterei
betrieben sie sind kalt und sie sind
laut und man muss schreien und wir
wissen dass durch die kälte sich aero
sohle feuchtigkeits tröpfchen und auch
viren viel besser in der luft halten
können und dadurch auch besser eine
übertragung stattfinden kann
beim schreien werden diese tröpfchen
größer die die die übertragung ist
einfach auch wahrscheinlich so dass wir
immer schon mal angenommen haben es gibt
eine wetterabhängigkeit und auch eine
temperatur abhängigkeit wie für alle
anderen coronaviren im übrigen auch dass
wir hier wahrscheinlich sehr deutlich
sehen wie kälte und trockene jahreszeit
passt das mit einem virus macht jetzt
halten sie dagegen brasilien ist ja ganz
anders aber wir wissen von der krippe
genau das gleiche das hohe
luftfeuchtigkeit und regen zu einer
häufigeren übertragung der grippe führt
deswegen auch im amazonas diese dieser
schwere aus buch also darf man kann er
jetzt nur mut maria 1 schindler aber ich
glaube ist es an der zeit wenn wir da
pragmatisch rangehen und einfach mal wir
haben andere coronaviren von denen wir
lernen können
wir haben die das grippevirus was ihr
auch um respekt
motorisches virus von dem wir lernen
können und wenn wir diese faktoren
zusammen ziehen dann sehen wir sehr
viele ähnlichkeiten mit dem jetzigen
neuen corona virus das heißt das ist
nichts was ihnen sorge macht oder anders
gefragt wie gefährlich kann das werden
wenn da 7000 menschen in quarantäne sind
möglicherweise noch viel viel mehr
infizierte gut das muss man gibt das
waren die meldung waren heute das muss
man jetzt erstmal abwarten und schauen
wie verbreitet das virus ist ist es ja
sehr lokal gewesen es war ja auch von
gastarbeitern wie ich das verstanden
habe so dass sie die sozialkontakte
vielleicht auch in den umfeldern gar
nicht so groß waren sondern dass eine
geschlossene gemeinschaft gewesen ist
aber dass das müsste man jetzt erst mal
aufarbeiten um das auch besser zu
verstehen ist im grunde die analogie zu
heinsberg ne da das in ihrem thema ist
es sogar ein größeres heinsberg bei mir
ja das heißt ein
ich hätte mich wir haben uns mal länger
darüber unterhalten und sie sagten schon
damals das ist eigentlich das was wir
viel mehr im auge behalten müssten diese
sogenannten super spreading ereignisse
wenn man sich das mal anschaut dann
spielen die ereignisse immer wieder eine
große rolle
ich hab das damals so verstanden dass
sie eigentlich sagten wenn wir das in
den griff kriegen
dann können wir auf der anderen seite
unser leben doch irgendwie einigermaßen
normal weiterleben
also ich glaube ist es wichtig zu
realisieren dass das virus
wahrscheinlich bleiben wird wir werden
es nicht austreiben können wir sind
keine insel ist wird ein teil unseres
alltags werden und die frage ist eben
wie wir damit umgehen
wir haben gelernt ist ja ein ständiger
lernprozess gerade dass das virus gerne
cluster also die ausbrüche clustern in
solchen super special events wir gehen
im moment davon aus dass zehn prozent
der infizierten für 80 prozent der
ausbrüche verantwortlich eine infektion
verantwortlich sind also ein ganz
kleiner anteil von menschen für viele
infektionen ich will zum beispiel ganz
genau ist der filter ist eine kelter mit
der trillerpfeife ganz genau per die
kappensitzung bergamo spiele
wir hatten
dann die trompete in berlin und immer
wieder diese lokalen hotspot ausbrüche
ich habe eine ihre zahl im kopf heben
würde ich gerne sie mal fragen ob sie
das für möglich halten
neulich gelesen das spiel alleine für 45
prozent der fälle nur in deutschland
verantwortlich ist es die hälfte
ist das denkbar dass er schon denkbar
wenn man annimmt dass das diesen cluster
effekt hat und das sehen wir viel mehr
aber das gibt uns auch was an die hand
nämlich eine das war genau versuchen
diese ereignisse von vielen menschen an
einem ort zu vermeiden
dann können wir das auch besser
kontrollieren es gibt uns aber auch was
weiteres an die hand nämlich wenn wir
einmal dort einen ausbruch haben dann
können wir auch sehr viel besser die
kontakte nach verfolgen weil wir wissen
dass ging von diesem einen ausbruch aus
da haben wir ein schönes bild das gerade
zum thema passt vielleicht kann die
regie das ist einmal ganz kurz zu spät
dieses bild aus berlin was geht ihnen
durch den kopf wenn sie so was sehen was
ist da zu erwarten ist es ist es auch
ich weiß natürlich genau so wenig wie
jeder andere aber es ist natürlich auch
ein experiment wir nehmen im moment an
dass die häufigen übertragungen in
geschlossenen räumen stattfinden
das dadurch natürlich besser die luft
steht hier ist der schlachterei betrieb
mit dem gerät gesprochen habe und das
virus besser übertragen werden kann
begehen nicht so sehr davon aus dass es
im freien die großen übertragungen gibt
das wäre aber jetzt einen fall wo man
sehen muss ob die infektionszahlen in
berlin hoch gehen und zumindest wie ich
das verfolge gibt es vermehrt
infektionen zum beispiel neukölln aber
auch die damit zusammenhängen sondern
als andere frau das weiß man nie
peking regelt teile der stadt auch
wieder ab plötzlich kommt lachs in den
verdacht dass das lachs schneidebretter
usw
unsaubere hygienische verhältnisse dort
damit etwas zu tun haben was denken sie
darüber und es gibt das gerücht dass es
sich dort um ein virus handelt das
mutierte ist also eine neue form dieses
virus man sie sind virologe und und wenn
ich etwas mittlerweile verstanden habe
für leute die in der hiv forschung
führend sind so wie sie die beschäftigen
sich an vorderster front mit der natur
und dem charakter dieses virus das heißt
wie groß ist die gefahr dass das mutiert
und vielleicht gefährlicher wird ja es
ist für mich wirklich auch interessant
meine ganzen kollegen aus der hiv
bereich hat ja so sehen dass wir
irgendwie ein video calls zu kurve 19
jetzt darüber reden und nicht mehr über
hiv die es gibt aber sehr viele
parallelen und auch die art der pandemie
und den umgang der pandemie aber jedes
virus mutiert und es ist auch
wahrscheinlich dass sich das corona
virus immer weiterentwickelt oder wir
wissen auch dass es weit sich
weiterentwickelt aber also wenn man das
jetzt mal vermenschlicht das virus
infiziert den körper und möchte da gerne
lange bleiben weil es sich wohl fühlt
natürlich denke es nicht und das auch
kein lebewesen das nur als fußnote dazu
gesagt und dadurch das immunsystem was
angreift entwickelte sich in eine
richtung dass es nicht so gut
angegriffen werden kann aber dann
gleichzeitig auch schwächer wird und wir
gehen eher davon aus und das sehen wir
für fast alle viren dass sie im laufe
der evolution schwächer geworden sind
wir wissen ist natürlich für das neue
corona virus nicht aber eine
abschwächung wäre zum beispiel dass es
mir in die nase geht leichter übertragen
wird und uns länger nervt aber dadurch
auch nicht so tödlich ist weil es nicht
tief in der lunge es ist ein sehr
interessanter punkt ist da ist das die
erklärung dafür warum wir können jetzt
mal ein bisschen bilanz ziehen sozusagen
nach diesen vielen monaten
wenn man sich die kurven mal anschaut
die entwickeln sich in fast allen
ländern egal was die länder machen
ähnlich also ich finde das auch
natürlich köpfe schaue ich mir die
zahlen auch sehr genau an auch von den
anderen ländern
und ich glaube nicht dass es
zurückzuführen auf die mutation sondern
ist es eher einmal der der ein
wettereffekt den wir sehen aber auch
dass wir gelernt haben damit umzugehen
und auf weltweit gelernt haben damit
umzugehen
wer großveranstaltungen gibt es fast
praktisch nirgendwo mehr wir sind auf
abstand gegangen wir haben hygieneregeln
wunsch gelernt und ich denke das ist
eher der effekt den wir sehen wenn man
jetzt schweden mit deutschland und
norwegen oder so vergleichbar ist
auch in meinen augen noch nicht das
letzte wort gesprochen das heißt für sie
ist dieser schwedische sonderweg nicht
gescheitert jemand wie karl lauterbach
sagt dieser schwedische sonderweg war
eine sackgasse die ist gescheitert der
eine sehr hohe sterblichkeit bezogen auf
100.000 einwohner jeweils sie glauben
das nicht
nun der in meinen augen kann man noch
nicht sagen der schwedische sonderweg
ist gescheitert weil wir der schwedische
sonderweg ja immer noch stattfindet und
es ist interessant für mich zu
beobachten dass sie nicht ein
geschwungen sind und gesagt haben wir
ändern jetzt unsere vorgehensweise
sondern wir hat behalten sie bei auch
hat ja die norwegische premierminister
soderbergh gerade gesagt ach wären wir
doch mehr den schwedischen weg gegangen
also es gibt da schon auch zwei seiten
der medaille
warum sagt sie das ist der gedanke
dahinter
sie sagt man sich ja keine ideologen
aber sie hatte ihre leute auf die sie
hört ja also ich glaube letztendlich und
das ist auch vielleicht etwas woraufhin
uns hin bewegen ist dass der mittel
keiner keiner weiß den richtigen weg
einer weiß die richtige wahrheit und der
mittelweg ist vielleicht auch der
richtige weg einer so gegangen ist aber
sie meinte eben dass bestimmte
schließung zum beispiel der kitas und
schulen vielleicht nicht notwendig
gewesen wären in norwegen auf mobbing
bezogen der vom schwedischen weg her
natürlich haben wir sehr viele
todesfälle gehabt und mussten sehr viel
beklagen und das ist vor allem weil das
in die pflegeheime reingekommen ist das
virus sehr schnell da war kein guter
schutz da aber die kurven haben 5000
tote
wir haben 8000 ungefähr so also die
kurvenhatz millionen einwohner wir haben
80 millionen also das ist schon immer
sterben hat die man da jetzt im moment
den schweren sieht aber die kurve
verhält sich ganz
nase und schweden wie in allen anderen
teilen europas auch und halten sie fest
an ihrer aussage am ende des jahres
werden wir keine über sterblichkeit
sehen am ende des jahres werden wir im
grunde zahlen haben wie in jedem anderen
jahr zuvor auch nun gut ist kommen also
man muss die sind ja immer einem
dauerhaften lernprozess und als ich das
ganz am anfang gesagt habe da habe ich
gesagt ich stelle das als hypothese auf
genau mittlerweile rede ist von einer
position wo ich auch sehr viel mehr
gelernt habe
wir sind durch eine unter sterblichkeit
anfang des jahres durch gegangen weil
wir durch unsere hygienemaßnahmen es
erreicht haben dass die wir die grippe
sehr gut eingewöhnt haben also diesem
jahr sein amt quasi ausgefallen war es
war wirklich nicht keine große
sterblichkeit durch die grippe
danach sind wir bei einer 8 prozentige
sterblichkeit drei prozent höhere
sterblichkeit kommt und jetzt sind wir
auf der normal sterblichkeit so dass man
von der kurve wenn man die kurven
übereinander legt eigentlich von einer
normal sterblichkeit ausgehen muss so
eine über sterblichkeit wie sie wieder
2018 gesehen haben die hat nicht
stattgefunden wo wir 25.000 glaube ich
war ungefähr hatten gut dass eine
schätzung wir sehen eine deutliche über
sterblichkeit
das heißt ich erinnere mich an einen
satz von ihnen sie sagten das ist nicht
das killer virus zu dem was manchmal
machen
ich denke es ist wichtig da zwei seiten
zu sehen bedürfnis ich habe auch immer
gesagt wir dürfen das virus nicht unter
stilisieren also ist es eine
gratwanderung die wir gemeinsam gehen
wir befinden uns ja alle in der gleichen
pandemie und wir dürfen es aber auch
nicht überdramatisieren und passe
natürlich angst macht mir auch angst
gemacht hat sind die bilder aus italien
die bilder aus new york oder aus
brasilien wo man jetzt wirklich sehr
clever sein sie hat dass das ist etwas
was an natürlich keinen unbeeindruckt
ist und darum denke ich ist das auch
eine richtige entscheidung gewesen von
der regierung das situativ zu sagen nein
wir schauen jetzt erstmal mit dem hammer
drauf und wir stoppen alles damit wir
was das virus ist daher
aber es ist trotzdem nicht dass
killervirus sagen sie das ist etwas mit
dem man leben kann
schauen sie mal ja wir haben vier
coronaviren die bei uns heimisch sind
wir sagen in dem ich das letzte von
denen es rund 600 800 jahre in den
menschen übergegangen und habe vor 600
jahren 600 800 jahren genau können was
natürlich nicht sagen einige ein paar
tausend jahre her und die menschheit hat
trotzdem überlebt dass das natürlich das
problem ist mit dem auch diese anderen
coronaviren haben bewirken todesfälle
das ist aber gar nicht so gut studiert
bisher bei uns nie interessiert haben
und wir wissen gar nicht erotisch
sterblichkeit von den anderen papieren
sind sicherlich ist dass die
sterblichkeit von diesem corona virus
höher und das liegt daran weil wir
komplett jungfräulich mit diesem virus
konfrontiert sind also keiner oder kein
mensch dieses virus bisher hatte und
eine immunität in seinem körper
aufgebaut hat diese immunität aber wenn
man die zum beispiel als kinder gehabt
hat wenn man dann wieder infiziert und
wieder infiziert dann ist das eine
schwächere verlaufen ist so ein
typischer grippaler infekt den wir dann
durch machen aber die anderen
coronaviren machen rund zehn bis 30
prozent unserer grippalen infekten im
winter aus also es ist etwas was wir
auch kennen und wenn wir uns auf die
literatur zurück beziehen diese
horrormeldungen von neuro invasion durch
durch das virus das kennen wir von den
anderen coronaviren ml 63 zum beispiel
benutzt den gleichen rezeptur wie das
saas kopf 2 wir werden jetzt der biologe
nach total interessant ich also am
hörten gebannt zu den gleichen rezeptor
und für eine 63 wurde zum beispiel bei
kindern ein das kawasaki-syndrom
beschrieben durch die infektion also das
sind dinge die wir aus der literatur
lernen können die verfahren den anderen
coronaviren lernen können damit wir
einen pragmatischeren blick auf das neue
virus haben
dass es sich nicht nur darum handelt ist
es ein virus was uns angst machen sollte
sondern und sowohl unser immunsystem als
auch unsere ärzte haben erfahrungen mit
diesem virus vorher gesammelt bevor wir
zu frau preißler kommen die das
natürlich mit großem interesse hört was
sie gerade erzählen weil sie hatte es
heißt ihnen ist dazu viel angst da wird
so viel gewarnt da wird zu viel
sozusagen der teufel an die wand gemalt
ich glaube es ist natürlich am anfang
als wir das neue virus bei uns hatten
das hat angst gemacht das hat auch mir
angst gemacht ich hatte ja selber in
meinem engen familienkreis zwei ältere
menschen mit vorerkrankungen wie
infiziert waren und ich habe wirklich
angst gehabt dass sie einen schweren
verlauf haben können aber die was wir
gelernt haben seitdem ist dass das virus
natürlich nicht zu bagatellisieren ist
und auch eine tödliche erkrankung ist
mit einer sterblichkeit von rund 0 4
prozent wie wir es aus götter davon
ausgehen aber ist trotzdem nicht ein
virus ist wie andere viren die bei einem
prozent oder 10 prozent liegen zb das
erste saas virus hatte eine
sterblichkeit von 9,6 prozent das ist
ein ganz 2003 2002 ist eine andere
hausnummer
und ich denke dass wir jetzt bei dieser
rückbesinnung auch mit der niedrigen
zahl der infektionen wie auch anfangen
können dann mit einem pragmatischeren
blick darauf zugehen bei eins ist sicher
wir haben keine alternative mit dem
virus umzugehen als teil von unserem
alltag werden zu lassen und wir müssen
bestimmen wie dieser alltag aussieht
sind das hat den gedanken nehmen wir
gleich später nochmal aufbau preißler
ich erinnere mich immer noch an dieses
gespräch mit ihnen vor ein paar wochen
das ging mir damals wirklich unter die
haut dieser satz als sie sagten das ist
wie bei vollem bewusstsein zu ertrinken
sie hatten sich infiziert bei ihrem mann
der im skiurlaub in österreich war das
noch mal deutlich zu sagen die
österreicher sind da wahrscheinlich
selber opfer das wurde irgendwann mal
eingeschleppt von irgendwoher von ihnen
touristen das video es kommt ganz sicher
nicht aus ist ursprünglich sondern
ganz woanders ja wie auch immer ihr mann
hat sich in österreich infiziert hat sie
dann auch angesteckt und sie hatten dann
einen dieser berüchtigten schweren
verläufe ich habe mich so die ersten
tage war einigermaßen okay
und dann so nach tag 89 kippte das wenn
sie an diese zeit zurück denken welche
was ist das gefühl dass bei ihnen heute
noch hoch kommt da ist eine unbekannte
krankheit war hat mich das überwältigt
es ist so schwer finde ich sich auf eine
krankheit einzulassen und zu sagen wir
machen das jetzt wenn man nicht weiß wie
der verlauf ist wir gehen jetzt drei
monate später büschelweise die haare aus
ich stehe morgens auf und mein kopf ist
voller haare und ich fahre jetzt dass
das eine folge von corona sein kann und
das ist ziemlich typisch ist und dass
die chinesen das auch schon beobachtet
haben
und wenn ich das vorher gewusst hätte
dann wäre ich bei den ersten malen wenn
man sich ins haar fest und dann hat man
im budget von hahn eine hand nicht so
erschrocken gewesen was ist die
situation mit ja
das ist im moment so aber es gibt auch
schon weil ja andere vor uns schon krone
erfahrung gesammelt haben
ein happy end hoffentlich ich werde
winterfell haben und das geht also
hoffentlich wieder vorüber geht es ihrer
lunge sie haben damals berichtet das ist
mir auch so in erinnerung geblieben sagt
ich kann nicht mal mit meinen kindern
sie haben drei kinder ein kinderlied
singen
mir fehlt die luft ja jetzt wie geht
ihre lungen ich hatte inzwischen einen
sehr guten lungenfunktionstest und
tatsächlich habe ich vor einem 100 nach
dem guten lungenfunktionstest gedacht
jetzt wird alles gut und dann habe ich
mich ans bett meiner jüngsten gesetzt
und habe angefangen eine gute nacht lied
zu singen sie hat es nicht mehr erkannt
sie ist oft gestand rausgegangen weil
sie nicht erkannte dass das jetzt das
abendlied sein sollen
und das zeigte mir eben auch dass es
nicht ausreicht eben eine gute
funktionstüchtige lunge wieder zu haben
sondern wenn man so eine krankheit hatte
dann muss man auch wieder üben da muss
man sein das werk trainieren und dann
muss man eben auch singen wieder üben
das ist ein instrument und seitdem
trällern
wieviel und meine töchter lassen sich
ihre lieblingslieder vorsingen
es wird besser das heißt dass mit der
lunge geht aufwärts das mit den haaren
war mir neu das hat mich so als symptom
noch gar nicht gehört
riechen sie schmecken sie ganz normal
als es so schwer krank war weiter im
krankenhaus und habe dort nicht gegessen
das wegen er kannte ich diese
beobachtung nicht machen ich bin auch
gefragt worden aber es ging mir nicht
gut genug
deswegen habe ich keinen geschmack
gehabt wenn man nichts ist aber mein
mann hat das beobachtet dem 4
der geschmack und der hatte auch
tatsächlich noch eine menge oder noch
eine weile damit zu tun
inwiefern punkten womit noch nirgendwo
er hatte noch eine weile schwer und geht
auch das gehört ja ganz offensichtlich
klar habe ich die auskunft erhalten dass
es auch von alleine wieder weggeht und
er war auch viel länger erschöpft als
ich nun war ich im krankenhaus und bin
natürlich umsorgt worden und habe
medikamente bekommen er nicht und das
als ich dann schon wieder anfing
rehabilitationssport zu machen war er
noch zu erschöpft dafür und musste hat
ein bisschen länger gebraucht so jetzt
sind wir in einer neuen phase in der
neuen situation und sie sagen es sind
vor allem die sozialen nebenwirkungen
und auswirkungen die mir jetzt zu
schaffen machen ist es ernsthaft so dass
sie angefeindet werden so nach dem motto
sie sind diejenigen die die solche so
wird es dann geschrieben und auch gesagt
die die solche in die stadt gebracht
haben diese art von anzahlungen erleben
sie als die das gespräch mit herrn
professor strikt eröffnet haben da haben
sie beispiele gebracht und haben gesagt
der kellner oder der barmann nicht sei
der täter der mit der trillerpfeife mit
der trillerpfeife und sie haben das wort
täter benutzt ja das war die analogie
zum krimi also sowas ja ich keine frage
aber dieser gedanke dass irgendwo einer
ist der angefangen hat die solche und
das volk zu bringen und da waren also 45
prozent der deutschen infektionen wenn
ich das richtig fasching darauf zurück
also auf diesen trillerpfeifen man
zurückzuführen dann ist es glaube ich
nicht so abwegig dass man andere
menschen diese überlegungen auch an
stellen
er wusste dass auch nicht wahrscheinlich
das hatte man merkt es doch nicht kein
mensch steckt voller vorfreude einander
ich habe mich bei meinem mann angesteckt
und das obwohl wir uns nur eben einen
tag gesehen haben das hat der macht sich
bittere vorwürfe deshalb niemand geht
los und steckt jemand an diese
überlegung dass also jemand als
virenschleuder durch die gegend zieht
existiert eben bei den menschen weil
dieses virus ist auch wirklich mit sehr
viel angst die zum sehr viele emotionen
eine berichterstattung haben die eben
auch den den lockdown rechtfertigt und
menschen die risikogruppen angehören
isoliert sind wir haben ganze schatten
familien wir haben wir haben einsame
menschen die sitzen da und die fürchten
sich und ich glaube dass das dann dazu
führt auch gerade die sprache die wir
verwenden dass jemand dann auch jede
hemmung fallen lässt und man sich den
ihn sucht den er für den kompletten
lockdown verantwortlich macht oder für
isolation oder der fürchtet sich um
angehörige und dann komm texte zu stande
und computer schafft nochmal nähren in
sozialen netzwerken wurde beschuldigt
eben mord und totschlag und
körperverletzung eben in meine stadt
getragen zu haben
oder mir wurde angeboten mir beim
kofferpacken zu helfen damit ich wieder
gehe es ist gar nicht so lange her da
haben wir hexenprozesse gehabt ich
glaube viele menschen fühlen sich wohler
wenn man niemanden hat gerade bei einem
unsichtbaren virus oder einer krankheit
ja an allem schuld ist und kann sagen
die war es der war es die waren es dann
wenn sie den supermarkt gehen
erleben sie dann solche situationen ich
hab so was erlebt und es war keine
schöne erfahrung ich bin mit meinem mann
zusammen einkaufen gegangen kurz nachdem
unsere quarantäne aufgehoben war
und wir mussten auch einfach der
kühlschrank war leer und wir sind beide
in den supermarkt gegangen und
jeder brauchte einen korb zwei personen
auf jetzt dann auch zwei körbe wegen
abstand und sondern man ist also schon
im supermarkt und da kam mir eine dame
entgegen die ich nicht persönlich kenne
aber die mich erkannt und mich
beschimpfte als diejenigen die solche in
die stadt gebracht hatte die den
sicherheitsmann der da vorne aufpasst
dass jeder seinen wagen nimmt auf mich
aufmerksam machte und ich war noch so
schwach und so wehrlos ja also
empfindlich klar dass mich das richtig
fertig gemacht hat und wäre mein mann
nicht eben schon im supermarkt gewesen
dann wäre ich an dem tag wieder nach
hause gegangen also man schreckt dann
auch nicht davor die kinder dafür
verantwortlich zu machen
ja aber es gab eben auch eine zeit in
dieser pandemie wo kinder als
virenschleuder galten und wo die kinder
einrichtungen geschlossen wurden weil
man dachte kinder bringen eben das virus
mit oder gefährden dann ihre großeltern
und ich glaube viele menschen kennen den
unterschied im tatsächlich zwischen
infektion und inkubation nicht und
quarantäne
und nachdem ich nun eine der ersten in
meiner regionen mit geringer war hat
natürlich jeder überlegt bequem hatte
wer kontakte waren die kinder meine
kinder sind klein sie sind unterwegs die
besuchen ihre freundinnen und freunde
und das hat zu heftigen reaktionen
geführt und zum teil sehr unschön dann
als die quarantäne vorbei war waren die
kinder voller freude dass sie wieder am
sozialen leben teilnehmen können und es
gibt eben ganz schöne grausamkeiten
gerade kleinen kindern gegenüber wenn
gesagt wird meine mutter hat mir
verboten ich darf erst nach corona
wieder mit dir sprechen und so aber wir
haben eine sprachregelung gefunden
krone hat immerhin dazu geführt dass wir
als familie viel besser kennengelernt
haben viel mehr miteinander gesprochen
haben und inzwischen wissen meine kinder
dass sie auf solche sachen dann
antworten bei uns ist schon nach corona
und dann einfach auch sich umdrehen und
weiter gehen dorthin verstrickt wenn man
wenn man das so hört auch kinder ist
gerade so ein ganz normaler punkt und
war immer wieder in der diskussion
ich glaube die haben da auch große
fehler gemacht werden nicht die chance
genutzt um wirklich studien zu machen
bis heute warten werden ich hoffe
wirklich valide ergebnisse baden
württemberg winfried kretschmann
das sind ja jetzt nach vorne gegangen
und öffnen schulen und kitas wieder
quasi uneingeschränkt weil sie sagen
kinder sind nicht nur keine viren
schleudern sondern es gibt
offensichtlich sonne zeigt dass kinder
das ganze eher abbremsen was was glauben
sie was ein was ein fehler kitas und
schulen so kategorisch zuzumachen
ja wie ich das vorhin schon gesagt habe
wir sind ja einem ständigen lernprozess
und ich glaube ist es falsch jetzt
zurück zu blicken und sagen das war ein
fehler oder das nicht darum was zu
lernen
ja ich denke wir haben das gewinn fürs
nächste mal weil die nächste solche
kommt ne wir haben wir haben wir haben
viel gelernt und wir haben viel über
kinder gelernt
wir haben viel über die infektionswege
gelernt und das eben auch zum teil eben
durch die wirklich aktive unterstützung
also auch vom gesundheitsminister sparen
der wirklich auch ja wirklich ein
gesundheitsminister ist der studien
anstößt und sagt das müssen wir jetzt
lernen das müssen wir jetzt lernen das
freut man sich ja richtig dass jemand so
einem verantwortung und so eine energie
dahinter steckt die dass wir wussten
dass vorher nicht wir wussten vorher nie
von irgendeinem viralen infektion mit
respiratorischen eigenschaften wie die
kinder da eigentlich übertragbar sind da
erst mal davon auszugehen dass da
eigentlich so ein
virenschleuder ist es irgendwie
naheliegend weil da ja auch viele
zusammen kommen aber die daten zeigen
einfach jetzt vor allem auch jetzt die
daten von herrn kräußlich aus heidelberg
zeigen eigentlich relativ deutlich dass
bei kindern nicht eine höhere infektions
von denen eine höhere infektions gefahr
ausgeht als von erwachsenen oder weniger
was heißt das in der konsequenz
kindergärten und schulen aufmachen
gut es gibt eine abstufung dann wieder
bei den älteren jahrgängen vor allem aus
den daten aus schweden da weiß man es
nicht so genau ob kinder die schon durch
die pubertät gegangen sind aber die
daten die bisher vorliegen dass unter
zehn jahren eigentlich keine erhöhte
gefahr von ausgeht sondern eher im
gegenteil dass sie weniger infektiös
sind und sich auf weniger infizieren
per drosten sagt das anders posten waren
bis heute davor kindergärten schulen
aufzumachen karl lauterbach auch gut
aber auch die daten von herrn drosten
zeigen ja zumindest dass die ist keine
höhere infektion durch die kinder kommt
sondern er sagt er kann nicht zeigen das
ist eine höhere viruslast oder niedriger
wie es gibt also hat die null hypothese
belegt wie wir es wissenschaftlich sagen
das heißt sie werden dafür bundesweit
darauf will ich nur hinaus nach den
ferien bundesweit schulen kindergärten
auf wir müssen sehen wie die infektions
situation aussieht wir dann aber im
moment wenn es nicht so weiter verhält
würde ich wir haben aber aus meiner
sicht würde man nicht irgendwie
argumentieren dass die schulen
geschlossen sein sollten sondern ist es
ja wichtig für die kinder da sind ja so
viele andere soziale aspekte die da eine
rolle spielen über die wir da reden
und letztendlich ist die entscheidung
der politik aber wenn ich eine
empfehlung aussprechen würde dann würde
ich auch sagen dass die kinder ob kitas
auf un schulen auf sein sollten
okay das finde ich total spannend denn
schulen werden ja von
lehrern auf gesagt ja und in meinem
bundesland zb fehlen gerade ein drittel
der lehrer weil sie eben sich
zurückgezogen haben weil sie zu
risikogruppen gehören oder
vorerkrankungen haben wenn der
schulbetrieb wieder losgehen soll dann
bedeutet das ja auch das beschlossene
sache
genau in mecklenburg vorpommern eine
beschlossene sache dann bedeutet das ja
auch dass man ein personalkonzept haben
müsste und das bedeutet eben auch dass
man in hygiene konzept haben muss dass
man sich überlegen muss wie geht es
weiter mit den lehrkräften die wann
hören wir auf die zu hause zu lassen wie
geben wir ihnen aber auch die sicherheit
sich nicht zu infizieren denn sie sind
eben gerade keine kinder ich finde dass
also ziemlich interessant und ich bin
ihrer meinung es gibt so viele kinder
die wir gerade nicht sehen und die
vielleicht gerade die halle durch machen
eltern mit mit psychischen
beeinträchtigungen suchtproblem die sich
nicht um ihre kinder kümmern deswegen
ist der druck glaube ich auch auf die
echse drittel so hoch
diese kinder einrichtungen wie das
öffnen sind wir sehen ganze schatten
familien ja gar nicht aber wie geht man
dann in einer einrichtung damit um dass
da eben erwachsene menschen sind die
sich vielleicht nicht bekommen
wir machen die christen dazu wie machen
wir das ja ist ja jetzt beschlossen
brauchen wieder besondere maßnahmen
bekannt oder
nun also das ist ja ganz schwer eine
schule und ein klassenzimmer und ein
alle jahrgänge über einen kamm zu
scheren dabei aber wenn wir jetzt erst
mal von tätern ausgehen haben die
studien und mehrere andere studien
mittlerweile auch gezeigt dass es keine
höhere infektion durch auch von kindern
ausgeht und keine höhere infektionsrate
bei kindern gibt dann ist natürlich die
die sorge der lehrkräfte dadurch
gemindert dass die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass kinder infiziert sind einfach
geringer
erstmal ist aber jeder von uns hat
natürlich eine situation immer mal
wieder wo er sich potenziell infizieren
könnte und daher muss man je nach
situation jena
schule monitoren abstriche machen testen
das hängt aber also man kann da wirklich
nicht hatte sich schon klar es ist das
also zum schluss gefragt ist das
sozusagen vielleicht dass das wichtigste
was sie auch für sich gelernt haben aus
dieser geschichte
wir haben uns ganz am anfang dieser
geschichte hier getroffen dann standen
sie irgendwann massiv in der kritik
wegen nicht geheim bleibt studie die
durch sehr sehr wertvoll war sondern
wegen des umgangs mit der heinsberg
studie da gab es plötzlich das gefühl da
hat sich die politik sozusagen diese
studie genommen hat die gekapert und hat
sie sozusagen benutzt um bestimmte
politische interessen voranzutreiben den
schweizern armin laschet hatten sie
manchmal das gefühl ich ich ich ich bin
da wieso sie haben es doch ich mal ein
asberger patient genannt einer der
sozusagen dinge sieht die anderen nicht
sehen
unter stehen dann einfach eingeprügelt
wird um mittlerweile gibt es einen
vernünftigen umgang mit der ganzen
situation also ich weiß als
wissenschaftler und biologe schaut man
ja erstmal nur auf die daten und die
fakten ließ dazu gibt und man hält sich
von den emotionen erst mal so weit es
geht fernen man wüsste auch nicht ganz
gefeit
da hab ich auch vorher gesagt dass ich
auch selber meine sorgen und ängste
dabei hat aber natürlich wenn man diesen
blick von den daten her erst mal hat
gibt es bereiche die die man sehr anders
wahrnimmt und auch gar nicht bewusst ist
dass es da so eine emotionale debatte
dazu die ich im übrigen vollkommen
verstehen kann ich kann verstehen dass
eltern und die lehrer angst haben davor
sich in schulen zu infizieren weil das
ist ja ein ein klassenzimmer oder eine
gruppe von nicht zu kontrollierenden
jungen menschen klar die potenziell ein
erreger sein können und wir könnten von
unserer seite ja nur die daten dazu
beisteuern dass die infektion weniger
hofes und das ist eben ein sehr
abstrakter blick also da auf der einen
seite die daten und die einschätzung
oder auf der anderen seite die emotionen
zusammenbringen das ist etwas was wir
als gemeinschaft eben versuchen müssen
und dazu zähle ich eben auch die medien
dass sie das nicht dass sie das auch
wegen dieser neutralität eben auch die
daten und erkenntnisse vermitteln und
ich sagen wir eine hat recht oder der
andere abrecht bei am ende hat
eigentlich keiner recht ist es immer ein
mittelweg ich danke ganz ganz herzlich
ich nehme daraus einen gewissen
optimismus und eine gewisse gelassenheit
und eine gewisse selbstverantwortung
eigenverantwortung die wir auch
übernehmen müssen das ist es doch
eigentlich also grundstimmung bin ich
glaube ich immer erst mal ein optimist
und das sollte man auch in einer
pandemie seien ja aber ich glaube dass
die frage nach der selbstverantwortung
eine sehr wichtige frage dabei ist weil
wenn ein 82-jähriger altenheim ist finde
ich gebührt ihm schon der die würde und
der respekt zu fragen ob er denn seine
angehörigen sehen will ob ihm ein andern
worten des corona virus jetzt nicht so
wichtig ist wie die angehörigen zu sehen
das ist eine wichtige menschliche
philosophische frage die nicht von
virologen beantwortet werden ist ja eine
frage geben ob eine selbstverantwortung
in solchen fällen nicht wirklich
entscheidender ist